hello everybody my name is Mark phlegm
welcome to let's play hide now this is a
game that I've been hinting a long time
and if you're like wow what is going on
no this is what the graphics of hide are
not about hitting that is a long time
because ever since I played slender the
eight pages the very first one and I
haven't touched this in a long time I
don't know if they update it but
basically the premise is you're like an
escaped convict or something or ever but
you'll see why it's familiar very very
shortly because they think I see what I
think I see now the graphics are low res
but like I've said before because this
game Niva here is the reason why this
game persecution you collect oh you you
collect sorry the game like just alt-tab
so we should still be back no perhaps in
three two one
Bing yeah so okay I think you see oh
that's it that's the thing the game is
called hide because there are these
things that come after you when you find
the pages and I think I found one bad
Mike snuck off on me and the more pays
as you find the harder it is get away
like seriously you can hear the thing
you can just hear it I don't know what
it is because it's almost impossible to
see but you can tell it's got a
spotlight it's got a little flashlight
that it uses to try to fly to you you
can hide by pressing the spacebar and
there are a few there in there like
locations in this game and if you
couldn't tell it's snowing so you're on
the snow and that thing's way over there
now I don't know what play it very much
so I don't know what the mechanics of
thing are all I know is that there are
five pages and spotlights going in the
background this was made like an I don't
know just like a few days why you got I
don't remember but the link is in the
description of a baby it seemed for the
kind of winter
you can see it you can see him he's
there okay ray five of five I think
these are like crimes that this guy's
committed then I don't know I hear one I
hear one oh crap oh crap oh crap oh oh
crap I've seen that before it's like a
helicopter that goes overhead makes it
easier for the other guys to spot you
[Music]
yeah I keep hearing he's right there I
can hear him you can like do your best
I don't even know how well like
crouching down hides you press the
spacebar dock quote-unquote high no God
here comes like an airship for a
helicopter I don't know but it's got a
massive spotlight they're gonna get me
we're gonna find me no no go away find
somewhere else go somewhere else go
somewhere else
go somewhere else oh crap ah that's the
thing that's the thing oh god this game
is hard I don't think I've ever gotten
more than two pages because they're so
spread out you could kind of got a
backtrack and one dot
know what that thing is ah anything
it is anything okay no no no no no
you're gonna find me you're gonna buy me
so hard to tell where everything is like
things are kind of mana color and Monica
okay I hear I hear a dingy dong Yi is
that I mean I'm close oh crap oh crap oh
I'm right out in the open he's got me I
found four or five how did I find four
of five I have no idea guys I have no
idea but that's hide that is hide whoo
all right so I just wanted to give you
guys a quick view of this game I'm not
gonna play there because I want you guys
playing I've played it before
I have never managed to beat I didn't
even though I got four of five there but
either way um I want I want to challenge
you guys if you guys play this game and
can beat it let me know and if you have
a strategy to do it let me know as well
like back when I first played this I
played a lot and I played it like over
and over and over again and I couldn't I
couldn't manage to finish it so if you
guys managed to and know how to beat it
let me know I would love to know in the
comments below so thank you guys again
for watching click the annotation for
more videos that I've done and as always
I will see you in the next video bye bye